ça il y a trois catégories il y a ceux
qui disent bah finalement bon en gros on
va continuer comme ça ça c'est Monsieur
Fillon monsieur Macron et puis il y a
ceux qui disent la deuxième catégorie ce
sont ceux qui disent on va renégocier
les traités c'est notamment Madame Le
Pen on vient de voir encore monsieur
belle confirmé c'est Monsieur Mélenchon
et puis c'est Monsieur cheminade c'est
Monsieur duupupignant et puis la trème
catégorie il y en a qu'un c'est moi
c'est c'est celui qui dit que après 60
ans on ne peut plus 60 ans de
construction européenne on peut plus
modifier les traités concrètement on
pourrait toujours théoriquement mais
concrètement on ne le peut plus la
situation est une situation de blocage
et dans cette situation bien en adulte
on va faire ce que font les Britanniques
qui sont un grand peuple les
Britanniques ce sont ceux qui ont
défendu les libertés publiques depuis
800 ans depuis la Magna Carta de 1215
c'est pas un peuple extrémiste c'est un
peuple extrêmement pragmatique et ben
nous on dit voilà on va lancer la
procédure de sortie de c'est pas la même
chose hein on peut pas établir le
parallèle ça n'a rien à voir le brexit
et frxit quand on abandonne une monnaie
c'est une onde de choc
considérable ça ça on peut on peut
parler de l'abandon de la monnaie mais
ils sont quand même en train de sortir
de l'Union européenne donc Président
vous président François Cino le
lendemain de votre élection vous sortez
de l'Europe bah je sors pas de l'Europe
ce que je fais moi je suis respectueux
du droit toujours et donc je lance la
procédure de l'article 50 du traité de
l'Union européenne comme vient de le
faire madame sans consulter les Français
outre mesure pourquoi je consulterai les
Français je vais pas leur demander par
ensuite par référendum s'ils sont
d'accord pour je mette en œuvre le
programme pour lequel je viendrai d'être
élu considéz que c'est un référendum de
fait mais c'est c'est pas un référendum
je sa votre progr programme voilà c'est
comme à ce momentl on pourrait aller
loin une fois qu'ils auraient voté il
faudrait que je fasse un autre
référendum pour savoir s'ils sont
d'accord pour je metre en ure le
référendum non j'ai un programme et si
je suis élu sur ce programme évidemment
je reconnais qu'avec les les précédents
de Monsieur Sarkozi et de Monsieur
Holland je reconnais qu'on va qu'on est
un peu on a perdu l'habitude qu'un
président de la République nouvellement
élu mettre le programme en œuvre qui
pour lequel il a été élu mais c'est
quand même ce que je faer moi et donc je
demanderai je mettrai en œuvre l'article
50 il y a une ouverture d'une
négociation avec les partenaires ça va
très bien se passer d'ailleurs regardez
ça se passe très bien avec le
Royaume-Uni ça n'est pas le Royaume-Uni
n'est pas tombé dans l'Apocalypse
rappelez-vous madame ro ils sont pas
sortis encore hein ils sont pas sortis
en son pas s pasur ils ne sont pas
sortis mais rappelez-vous ce qu'avait
dit Madame Madame Christine Lagarde la
directrice générale du Fond Monétaire
International elle s'était rendue au
mois de juin de l'année dernière et elle
avait dit si jamais vous votez pour le
brexit dans les jours qui viennent ça va
être l'Apocalypse financière ça va être
un effondrement des marchés financiers
on a appris au début de cette année
c'est le gouverneur de la Banque of
England lui-même qui a dit qu'en fait
toutes les prévisions apocalyptiques
avaient été fausses et puis je constate
que les conversation pour la sortie de
l'Union européenne par le Royaume-Uni
ont commencé ben je constate que les
choses se passent bien la France n'a pas
rappelé son ambassadeur à Londres le
Royaume-Uni reste relié au reste du mond